[Music]
very few americans have been personally
targeted by russian president vladimir
putin but that's been part of investor
bill browder's life for years now since
taking on the kremlin over the death of
his friend and lawyer sergey magnitsky
in a russian prison magnitsky had been
investigating russian government
corruption on behalf of browder's
company
that story and so much more as part of
browder's new book it's called freezing
order a true story of money laundering
murder and surviving vladimir putin's
wrath it chronicles his battle to pass
the magnitsky act legislation used to
sanction human rights abusers in russia
and worldwide
and brown has also been living under
constant threat from russia the book is
published by simon schuster that's a
division of cbs's parent company
paramount global uh and mr browder bill
joins us now thank you very much for
being here and i do mean that more so
than with other guests because a lot of
people in your situation would not be so
public and to be clear your situation
you are very much on the personal radar
of vladimir putin to the point where
he's brought you up at global press
conferences and proposed trading
russians for you as a prisoner
yeah i mean you know i would have never
imagined 20 years ago that i would be uh
putin's number one foreign enemy and um
you know here i am
uh in this crazy situation uh and it's
been going on for for you know many
years now where they've been targeting
me with arrest warrants with death
threats with kidnapping threats with
lawsuits chasing me all over the world
it's um it's been quite remarkable what
has that taught you about putin's
character well you know we're all
looking and trying to figure this guy
out and i know him and what i've seen
with vladimir putin is that he is a
escalator he always escalates he never
backs down
and his thing is he never wants to show
weakness um he never wants to compromise
and from my own experience watching him
in a microcosm of a sort of a one murder
situation um he's now doing it on a
million murder type of situation basis
with ukraine
and what i'm so fearful of is that um he
isn't gonna back down in ukraine that if
he
is seen to be weak he will just do
something even more terrible and i i
dread to think what that's going to be
he also cares a lot about money his
money that's what got you into trouble
with them in the first place there was a
tax fraud that your company was pursuing
and you determined that putin himself
was profiting it makes me think that
sanctions if they hurt him personally
might have an effect do you agree or not
i totally agree so putin values
money more than human life and he's got
a lot of money i think he's worth 200
north of 200 billion dollars
and um he doesn't keep that money in his
own name he keeps that money in the name
of these oligarchs we all know about the
oligarchs with their yachts and so on
um and so if we want to sanction
vladimir putin we've got to sanction the
oligarchs and we're starting to do that
right now
and um even if he's not seeing it he is
seething right now thinking that his
money is no longer available to him but
let's talk about you bill for a second
because so many people who are working
with you
starting with your with your lawyer so
many people who are helping you in this
case are no longer with us i mean you
get a phone call that says i don't mean
to alarm you but never a good way when
the phone call comes and what were you
told in that phone call why does putin
still want to get you but so this was a
phone call from from a senior government
official u.s government official to say
that there is a kidnapping plot being
organized by the russians
to try to kidnap me take me back to
russia too effectively to probably kill
me
um
why do they want that because um i was
going after their money uh why was i
going after their money because my
lawyer sergey magnitsky had discovered
the theft of 230 million dollars and he
was he exposed it was killed over it and
i wanted to make sure that the people
who killed him face justice you call
that the most devastating heartbreaking
traumatic moment of your life do you
feel personally responsible in some ways
i do sergey um would still be alive
today if he hadn't been working for me
and i feel a tremendous burden of guilt
you seem to be devoting your life now to
make
when when sergey was murdered i made a
vow
uh to his memory to his family to myself
that i put aside everything else i was
doing and spend all of my time all my
resources and all of my energies going
after the people killed him to make sure
they face justice even though risking
your own life i marvel that you're still
here i'm so glad your wife is with you
you've got children i marvel that you
were still able to sit here with us at
the table today well sergey was in in
much more dire and dangerous
circumstances and stood up to them and
it's my duty to him to not back down
you know i want to go back to something
you said bill about vladimir putin you
said he never backs down and he's always
looking for the opportunity to escalate
presumably our intelligence agencies and
the world's intelligence agencies have a
similar assessment so do you believe
that if there was some type of an
escalation either nato or the united
states he would welcome that
well in a certain way um the one thing
that he the the one way you can stop him
is by showing strength that's the one
thing he respects he doesn't respect
weakness he doesn't respect negotiation
and so if we actually stood up to him
firm and tough
and put up a hard barrier to say a
no-fly zone for example in ukraine to
say you think we should do that i
absolutely think we do there's no
question even though people say that
could lead to another world war he's
leading us into another world war
anyways but but the point is if we put
up a no-fly zone we say vladimir you
know you put any of your planes into
ukraine they're going to get shot down
and if we shoot them down do you want to
have war with us he can't even defeat
ukraine um does he want to have a war
with nato he's a guy who respects
strength and that's strength yeah that
is a strategy some rational thought from
uh an investor who is a big foe of
vladimir putin bill browder thank you
very much the book his second the first
one was a bestseller the new one is
called freezing order it goes on sale
tomorrow